Speaker 1: We have just insane news.
News Corp Slack's Fox News is going to be
launching their own Weather Channel, if you
can believe it.
The week is reporting that Fox is launching
a weather streaming service and it is already
feuding with the Weather Channel.
Rupert Murdoch is looking to rain on the Weather
Channel's parade.
There's there's a nice line.
Murdoch is set to debut a new streaming service,
FOX, whether this fall with his company believing
that the, quote, sometimes staid world of
weather TV is ripe for disruption.
The New York Times reports FOX weather is
aiming to take on the Weather Channel, but
the Times noted that the latter company is
already throwing some shade at its new competitor.
Weather Channel chief content officer Naura
Zimet told The New York Times they couldn't
even get a headline headline right about Tropical
Storm Bill slamming a recent article on Fox
News's website claiming the storm posed a
massive threat.
I applaud Fox getting into the weather space,
but they should really leave the saving information
to the experts.
That is not really the issue for me.
The issue for me is the next aspect of this
that's addressed.
Zimet added that climate change is too important
to politicize and if they do that, they will
be doing Americans a disservice.
A Fox weather spokesperson pushed back, telling
the Times, quote, While the Weather Channel
is focused on trolling Fox News.com for unrelated
stories, Fox Weather is busy preparing the
debut of our innovative platform to deliver
critical coverage to an incredibly underserved
market.
When I hear that Fox weather says weather
is an underserved market, when it's a third
of the nightly local news on the 6:00 p.m.
news and basically every market on the 11:00
p.m. news and basically every market, if you
look at a half hour of local news, those those
half hour news shows, once you take out commercials,
it's twenty one minutes, often six or seven
of those twenty one minutes are weather a
third on.
And in addition to that, you have the Weather
Channel, in addition to that, everybody on
their phones has constant live weather.
And when there are notable weather events,
the major cable networks like MSNBC, CNN and
Fox cover weather.
So when I hear Fox weather say that weather
is underserved, what I'm hearing is there's
not enough climate denial, presented a science
and and packaged as if it is the Weather Channel.
And that is what I fundamentally believe that
this is about.
They make billions by playing political theater,
stoking polarization, stoking gridlock, allowing
the people who say Trump really won and all
of this stuff to just appear on their network,
they build that up and then they build themselves
up as the ones who will tell you the truth.
Why am I not seeing on the other networks
that Trump actually won?
Well, maybe it's because Trump didn't really
win.
No, it's because nobody but Fox will tell
me the truth.
That's the ideology and the attitude that
they sort of stoke in their audience and with
a fair amount of climate denial.
Right.
Remember the clips from Fox News, despite
it being bitterly cold in the winter in North
Dakota, in D.C., Democrats are talking about
climate change, those types of headlines.
So they've got the perfect audience for it.
And now they will smoothly make the switch
and say, hey, we'll also tell you the truth
about the weather and climate, which are actually
two different things.
Come on over.
This is what they are planning.
In a sense.
It's brilliant.
It's evil.
Genius, I guess, is what I would call it.
Weather is going to become a ratings maker
in the sense that it will now be a proud and
defiant alternative to the fake news weather
that the meteorologists on the Weather Channel
and elsewhere are giving you.
If it weren't so obviously going to work,
it would be worth laughing at.
But because it's probably going to work, it's
actually the type of thing we should be crying
over, creating an alternative narrative that
climate deniers can point to and say, no,
no, no, no, no.
Fox weather has a different perspective on
this.
It's extraordinarily dangerous and it will
be launching in a few months.
And I am genuinely horrified by what this
what this may do, because remember that there
is a virus in the US, which is people don't
even understand what are facts.
And whenever I say that, it sounds like I'm
using strange syntax because people assume
I'm saying people don't understand what the
facts are.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's worse.
People no longer understand what are facts?
What types of statement are empirical statements,
statements based on the scientific method,
for example, versus what are just opinions.
And when you don't understand what is a fact
and what is an opinion, which is what Fox
News specializes in, all hell breaks loose.
Apply that deranged system to weather now.
And it is a recipe for absolute and total
disaster.
I don't think I'm being exaggerated in how
dangerous this is, but I want to hear from
you.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and let me know your thoughts.
Remember that the David Pakman show is made
possible mostly through membership's people
like you who say, I'll sign up, you can go
to join Pakman dot com.
We
do a daily member only show we've got the
one hour a day show, but then we've got an
extra 15 to 20 minutes with behind the scenes
stuff and a lot of other things every day
for our members.
You can access it instantly when you sign
up at join Pakman dot com and of course the
coupon code is available better.
Twenty one will save you a bunch off of the
membership of your choice